Optimal at this altitude,
I can run flat out for a half mile before my hands start shaking.
No else are you posting a question?
I'm a cybernetic organism.
This episode of the Tim Ferriss show is brought to you by Linkedin.
More specifically,
I'm referring to Linkedin job recruitment platform,
which is a great way to find and hire the quality talent that you need in your
organization.
You already know,
of course,
Linkedin as the world's largest professional network,
and in fact 70% of the US workforce is already on Linkedin and 22 million
professionals view and apply to jobs on linkedin every week.
Given those numbers,
it's not surprising at all that there've been hundreds of thousands of
businesses that have posted to linkedin jobs over the past year alone,
and because linkedin considers skills,
experiences location and much more,
they just have better data to match and promote your job to potential
candidates.
The most qualified candidates,
unlike other generic job boards,
businesses have rated linked in jobs 40% better than job boards at delivering
quality candidates.
So check it out.
Go to linkedin.com/tim and get $50 off your first job post.
That's linkedin.com/tim for your $50 off today.
Terms and conditions apply.
This episode is brought to you by 99 designs whether you need a logo,
custom website,
APP,
book cover,
or anything else.
99 designs was created to make great design accessible to everyone that's you
and to make the process as easy as possible.
I've used 99 designs for years now.
I've used them for book covers,
some mock ups for the four hour body,
which went on to become a number one New York Times bestseller.
Illustrations of all different types for the multivolume,
the Tao of Seneca,
which you can check out and other graphic design projects for a long time now
and I've been very impressed by the quality of their designers and illustrators
and you don't have to take my word for it.
You should check out some of my projects@ninetyninedesigns.com forward slash Tim
I really encourage you to take a look because you will be impressed.
99 designs.com forward slash Tim nine nine designs has freelance experts in more
than 90 design categories in their platform.
Lets you work directly with one designer that you choose.
If you like their stuff,
which is what I did for the Tao of Seneca,
or you can get concepts from multiple designers and then pick your favorite.
So whether you're starting a business or just looking for extra design,
help,
resources,
etc. 99 designs has a solution right now.
You guys,
my listeners can receive a free $99 upgrade on your first design.
To check out your first free upgrade,
please visit 99 designs.com forward slash Tim and click the link on the landing
page.
You can also find their samples of projects from you guys,
listeners who've used 99 designs for logos,
apps,
even product packaging,
so check it out.
99 designs.com forward slash Tim.
Yeah.
Hello,
you crazy kids.
This is Tim Ferriss.
Welcome to another episode of the Tim Ferriss Show where it is my want to
investigate the habits and routines of world class performers to try to tease
out the various details so you might apply to your own life.
This episode is a very different format.
It is an odd one that has proven surprisingly popular for reasons that sometimes
I don't quite understand and that is a drunk dialing Q and a with all of you
guys,
which I've done a few times in the last few years and here's how it works.
I solicited phone numbers from listeners on Facebook and Twitter.
You want to receive a phone call from me,
which they put into a Google form.
Then I told people who the first say 10 to 20 we're going to be by posting it on
social media and then I started drinking and dialing,
answering questions and getting a little frisky along the way.
Uh,
in fact,
this one,
I came in hot,
started after a few preliminary drinks with friends on a weekend,
so it's double trouble.
I ended up covering topics including how to reassess existing projects,
specifically ones which you've put a lot of capital and time into using 80,
20 analysis and other tools.
How to learn to care less about what people think,
social perception and how to minimize herd mentality.
Not Saying I'm perfect in that regard,
but I'm pretty good and have approaches for sort of decreasing the perceived
pressure around all of those things.
A framework for thinking about entrepreneurship risk taking and how to cut your
teeth as a business builder or creator.
How to learn to ask better questions,
whether in dating or sales and how to let the silence do the work and so much
more.
And uh,
all that preamble out of the way.
Please enjoy this Tequila fueled Q and a with all y'all.
Okay,
Danny.
Hey Dad.
It's Tim Ferris.
Oh Hey Danny,
this is Tim Ferriss.
I drop my mic.
How are you?
Are you,
oh,
I'm a clicking into sixth gear was just sloppy gear.
So you're catching me at a good point.
This is just in the transition to probably 20% too much alcohol.
How are you doing?
I don't know man.
I don't mean to you.
I'm not quite sure.
Andy glass of wine.
Are you in right now?
Oh No,
we're,
we're dealing with straight Tequila.
So I would say four or five glasses in,
which is,
I'd say a pretty good spot.
It's not completely haphazard,
but it is a well lubricated.
Where are you at the moment?
I am throwing you some Lake City,
Utah,
honor you.
I'm in Texas at the moment.
I am the fine,
the fine city of Austin and the Republic of Texas.
Big Fan
of SLC though.
It's a good spot.
So how can I assist this evening?
What questions might you have?
What's your system do you use or have you used in the past essentially or
effectively stop caring about what other people opinions are about you,
your endeavors that you like that.
And then how do you go about building a world class supports this stuff.
These could both go for a while.
So I will try my best to provide a non bullshit answer to either or both.
Uh,
in terms of getting to the point where you care less or not at all about what
other people think.
Let me drill into your,
your personal case.
So what is,
what is there that you might want to do where caring about what other people
think is inhibiting your ability to execute,
whether for yourself or for the world at large in some capacity?
Yeah,
just because I grew up
in Germany,
family,
immigrated to Germany from Yugoslavia,
all of the war and genocide,
immigrant narrative,
if you're nobody,
and once you get a college degree is so naturally I'm competing against all of
my family members and cousins who are all electrical engineers,
mechanical engineers,
et Cetera,
et cetera.
So regardless of what idea of ambition or anything else that in that regard
staff to do that,
as long as I have a college degree,
nobody valued it and spinning your wheels and wasting your time.
Got It.
Okay.
So it's not,
it's so you're not then concerned about what perspective customers or people in
the marketplace think of whatever you're starting.
It's more of a question of family members,
especially getting out of the herd mentality,
right?
And just being able to actively break away from that and not be bogged down with
just some of the things that are going to happen.
Um,
you know,
within my own circle,
this is tougher.
This is tougher than the marketplace.
I would say tougher but not impossible.
I would recommend a few,
a few resources.
This is not something that I've personally experienced,
but it's something that a lot of my friends have experienced.
Uh,
it's very,
very common as you know,
with immigrant families,
right?
Whether,
uh,
I,
lot of my friends are first generation raised in the u s from India for
instance.
Uh,
exceptionally common.
If you are not an engineered lawyer or doctor or fill in the blank,
then all of your motives and the future prospects are suspect.
Uh,
what I have observed is that if you experience a degree of success and
entrepreneurship than all sins are forgiven and,
and ultimately people are very proud of what you've done.
A few resources that I might recommend that I've found helpful in navigating
maybe somewhat similar psychic space.
And then I've seen other people benefit from and that have come up a lot in
interviews on the podcast for instance,
as it relates to some similar life experiences.
One would be man,
search for meaning by Viktor Frankl.
Uh,
the second which has,
has come up a lot is the magic of thinking big by David Schwartz.
Um,
both of these books are,
are quite short.
I want to say both are certainly no longer than 250 pages and maybe less than
200 each.
So you could,
you could read each in an afternoon,
uh,
or certainly a single day.
And you know,
aside from that,
I would look for people who have done what you are trying to do,
namely succeed as an entrepreneur,
as the child of immigrants who have,
uh,
a security focused mindset.
If I could be so bold as to assume that's the case right now.
Yeah.
Uh,
and there are many,
many,
many such people to look to,
whether that's uh,
on the,
on the name brand side,
you can certainly pick and choose.
I'm more familiar with many of the Indian entrepreneurs who've done this based
on,
uh,
spending time with organizations like the Indus Entrepreneur,
Tai,
which may or may not exist any longer,
but it was certainly a,
a,
a major entity when I was first getting to know the bay area with nothing to my
name aside from really a piece of Shit,
hand me down green minivan.
Uh,
and,
uh,
I've,
I've always found those stories to be exceptionally inspiring but also to serve
as proof of concept for you to see that it can be done and that in fact those
people then end up not just being reconciled with their family,
but very respected and honored and talked about by their family at the same
time.
So I think studying historical cases is very useful,
uh,
in,
in a situation like this.
If you're setting,
certainly we already talked about it.
You already talked about it.
I'm not going to Belabor that.
Uh,
otherwise,
I do think that,
and a reach a Chada who's an Indian actress,
certainly more than that,
but talked about this in tribe of mentors when she,
I asked her what she did when she felt overwhelmed or unfocused and she would
ask,
so what,
so you really,
you write down your fear,
and this is different from fear setting,
but she would ask,
so what,
five to eight times,
let's just say,
and you'd write down your fear.
This happens.
So what?
And then you write the consequence or the proceeding generative year.
And then so what?
And then so what,
and by the time you really get to the bottom of one or two pages,
you realize that the teeth just aren't there.
Ultimately,
I'm making this up.
This may not be true for you,
but ultimately like your family will love you no matter what.
They're just busting your balls about this particular thing,
right?
Or if you fail an entrepreneurship,
you can always go get a job.
It may not be an electrical engineering,
but if you wanted to and had to,
you had a gun against your head,
you had to go find a job that your parents would approve of or your siblings and
approve of.
You could do that.
Right.
Or You could at least get on a path that would lead to one of those jobs and
therefore in and of itself,
be respectable to your family members.
So that's,
that's another tool in the toolkit potentially.
But I think that any modicum of success for gives all sentence,
right?
Yeah.
It is.
But look,
I am not,
I mean,
my grandfather was the first of his family born in the United States on one side
of my family.
And I never dealt with having parents who were first generation immigrants,
uh,
at all.
But,
uh,
certainly my parents had been unable to explain to anyone what Tim does for a
living for a really,
really long time.
I mean,
it was,
it was very,
very hard to explain.
And once I had a label like author or podcast or they can be used,
it made things a whole lot easier and they were very supportive.
I don't want to send,
my parents weren't supportive.
Uh,
they were.
But the labels and the success combine to give your parents or siblings a story
that makes sense for them and that they can convey to other people and you can
help them to develop that narrative,
if that makes sense.
And you can also help them to develop that narrative by introducing them to
documentaries or books or stories or articles about immigrants who have become
entrepreneurs.
First Generation Entrepreneur,
immigrants just filled the number one priority for all of these.
So it's interesting paradox.
Yeah,
I would,
I,
yeah.
And here's,
here's nothing I would say,
it doesn't make you weak to care about what other people think.
It makes you human as a homo sapiens would not have created,
I mean arguably destroyed also.
But what we have created without a concern for social perception and hierarchy,
that is just part of the programming that we experience as a human being.
And it's serves a lot of productive purposes.
So I wouldn't judge yourself too harshly for caring what other people think.
You just have to equally care about what you think.
Right?
Yeah.
And in a good way to learn to care about what you think is to take it out of
your head and to put it onto paper,
whether that's through fear setting through the five minute journal or something
like that,
morning pages and so on.
I really find that I cannot grapple productively with my own thoughts until I've
trapped them on paper in some fashion.
I appreciate that.
Yup.
So hopefully that helps.
If it doesn't,
I apologize,
but,
um,
what,
what else,
what else do you have?
For me?
Building a support system and just,
you know,
getting in the right network or group of people that you are in silicone valley
around a bunch of Angel Niecey's and kind of that tech industry,
which initially helped open a lot of doors for you and kind of broke down a lot
of barriers to help you get your foot in the door and you know,
become as successful as you are for or,
um,
in that feel.
Let's get specific.
So what do you need a support system for?
What are you trying to achieve?
What do you think you need one for?
Right.
And so I guess it just ties into going into,
which is my ambition of entrepreneurship and branching out and just essentially
doing my own thing and
okay.
Which is totally fine,
but their entrepreneurship is a very,
very broad,
right,
right.
I mean that could be any,
no,
no.
You don't have to apologize.
It's very common that people want to man their own ship and carve their own
course.
But it will help me to think about the question if we have some degree of
specificity.
And,
uh,
if you're trying to pick,
and uh,
this is something I've,
I've mentioned before,
but the five people with whom to associate with most,
whether they're in the form of books,
in person,
mentors or otherwise,
you do need the specificity to help you target,
whether that's a skillset or certain types of characteristics that you want to
develop.
Uh,
so what,
what do you want to do in the world of entrepreneurship?
I mean,
who are the people you aspire to be?
Like,
what are the projects that you would love to be a part of?
And uh,
you know,
where,
where are you in that journey also?
I mean,
do you have a company with 10 employees?
Do you have a,
a company with one employee?
Namely you do,
you have no company but you're thinking about starting something?
Where are you at the moment?
Moment.
Yeah.
I mean,
so for your concrete's essentially I'm looking at an individual sectors.
Your sound for like a Gary Vaynerchuk,
John D Rockefeller,
Steve Jobs,
obviously not aiming to hit those heights just cause there's so much luck
involved in that way.
Those are there.
You got to see the people that I brought to the forefront often and think about
off then.
Then as far as pulling the trigger,
I'm doing something.
I'm always down to the point of building something,
building up the systems to essentially having everything set up on my end but
then just never pulling the trigger and going live.
Right now I work at a small start up like San Francisco based actually.
Um,
we've have an office in your town.
There was operations,
um,
analysts and do a lot of building in salesforce.
But the saying the shy branch out,
do my own thing.
And uh,
the realm of social and chat or some sort of cross a hybrid between the two.
What do you want to get?
What do you think you might get through entrepreneurship that you don't get
through your current job?
Can it be the captain of my own ship?
I've never,
it never sat well with me kind of being that guy was like,
okay,
here's the job,
here's the role,
here's what we think you're capable of and here's your pay relative to what we
think your skill set is.
And what you can handle and then diamond and plan your life accordingly to that
and essentially just like to have more time than you'd be able to draw on my own
life,
my own agenda on my own calendar,
do whatever I want to do and that my will.
And then I'm also recently married on coming up on two years in Marion,
trying to start a family in the next couple of years.
So I'm essentially giving them a one up at better foundation than what I had
started.
And I just love the game of business.
Well,
if you had to start a business tomorrow,
you got fired and you need to start generating income within,
let's just call it eight weeks.
You have eight weeks of severance.
Oh,
we can make a 12 let's be generous.
You have 12 weeks of severance.
You have health insurance for a year.
Let's just assume,
right?
What would you do?
I'd go into ecommerce and Shopify and
fair and just to be something going.
What would you sell?
Probably Apparel.
Apparel.
Why would you sell apparel?
Now you're grilling me.
I feel like I could find some sort of niche to fill as far as the people
identifying with a group or industry,
whether it's,
I'm just throwing things out there for the sake of throwing things out there,
but whether it's geared towards entrepreneurship and I've seen a lot of things
trending where like crypto investors and big one,
stuff like that.
I know it's trendy,
it's not going to be long term,
but
just help me get from point a to point B.
Okay.
So here,
here's what I would,
here's what I would suggest,
uh,
as a,
as a framework for thinking about entrepreneurship.
Entrepreneurship is not mutually exclusive with employment.
And truth be told,
I think the best way to cut your teeth as an entrepreneur is doing so while you
have a paycheck.
Uh,
I even though people might think of me as a risk taker and someone with a high
tolerance for risk,
I don't think of myself that way.
And for the record,
I've interviewed people like Richard Branson for instance.
They do not think of themselves that way either.
Uh,
first and foremost,
they're looking at how to mitigate risk.
So I would suggest that if that is what you would do as an entrepreneur,
that you spend say every Friday night and Saturday for the next eight weeks
developing that business or Sunday afternoons and evenings,
whatever it might be,
so that you have the security of the paycheck you're receiving,
you are fulfilling your obligations to your employer while simultaneously
cutting your teeth and testing the assumptions that are underpinning your belief
that apparel and ecommerce could be the business that provides you with the
freedom you seek.
And,
uh,
there is no right answer here.
I should also emphasize in the sense that for better or for worse,
the American dream and the media machines that exist in our country highlight
the entrepreneurs who seemingly throw caution to the wind bet,
the farm and when big
that is not how most entrepreneurs succeed.
And in fact,
that is not how most humans,
uh,
achieve a life of fulfillment and financial security and contentment.
Uh,
there is no shame in determining that you are really,
really,
really good lieutenant or general who can execute on orders and take something
that would overwhelm other people in complexity or fill in the blank perimeter
and a turn a plan into reality.
That is an incredibly powerful gift.
And if you do that within the confines of a company that is in no way indicative
of a lower value than being an entrepreneur staring off into space and trying to
figure out what the fuck do it.
So I just,
even though I mean I am an entrepreneur because I am a shitty,
shitty,
shitty employee basically.
And,
uh,
I'm proud of that in some capacities,
but I'm also ashamed of that in other capacities.
I mean,
there are severe personality,
uh,
and interpersonal deficits that make my entrepreneurship a necessity and not an
option.
Does that make sense?
Right.
Um,
and,
uh,
furthermore,
I am not a good manager of people.
I'm very good at figuring out systems.
I'm very,
very,
very good at figuring out processes.
I am not a good manager of people.
I have certain Achilles heels including,
uh,
unreasonable impatience and perfectionism and other things that lead me to be
very difficult to work with,
uh,
and very difficult to work for.
Uh,
certainly,
and I,
and I don't wear those as a badge of honor.
I think those are handicaps in many respects and there's no way that I could
possibly be the CEO of say,
a publicly traded company.
It would not that I wouldn't pass go in a situation like that.
So I have my sweet spot.
Other people have their sweet spots and you are going to have your sweet spot
and I wouldn't judge yourself harshly at all if that ends up being a sort of a
special purpose weapon inside a company for doing x,
y,
and Z.
Right.
But the way you test your assumptions related to entrepreneurship is by doing so
in a moonlighting capacity.
So I would,
I would take what it is you think you could do when you quit your job and do
that now.
I wouldn't,
I wouldn't test those assumptions.
When you've already cut the umbilical cord and you no longer have the financial
security of a paycheck.
So I would do that now and I've seen a lot of really,
really,
really good companies started that way.
But you know,
for the sake of your sanity and financial security and also the security of your
family to be,
if you're considering moving on that,
uh,
I would absolutely moonlight.
Well that's going to mean is you're going to have to put in extra time in
addition to your job,
whether it's on evenings or weekends or otherwise.
And guess what?
Like that is what you're signing up for.
If you're,
if you choose to be an entrepreneur,
if you're currently working eight hours a day for at least the first six to 12
months,
you are going to be working,
you know,
1214 hours a day and almost without exception,
that is a foregone conclusion.
So you might as well get used to that in terms of additional hours per week and
see how you handle it psychologically,
physically and otherwise.
Because that is par for the course for at least the first six to 12 months
without any necessary guarantee of success,
uh,
in the,
in,
in the longer term.
So those are,
those are a few possibilities to consider,
but I would absolutely make sure that you moonlight and test your
entrepreneurial chops and develop your entrepreneurial skills while you still
have fulltime income.
Uh,
I think that's a very cautious but ultimately intelligent way to approach
things.
All right.
I appreciate your insight.
Uh,
alright.
Anything,
anything else?
I know that probably,
uh,
hopefully that's not completely underwhelming as recommendation,
but I would really,
I would really just fucking get to it.
Like,
if you're going to be an entrepreneur,
you don't have to wait until you quit your job.
Like start now.
Like start tonight,
start this weekend,
like just fucking get on it.
And it's like,
all right,
set up your Shopify,
start doing your market research to determine exactly what you're going to test
first and what you can dry test before you do any manufacturing.
Or are there options like teespring or otherwise that enable you to begin to
kick the tires and see if what you think is gonna resonate and sell actually
resonate itself,
so on and so forth.
Right.
No,
I have one more question that's not necessarily needed business or
entrepreneurship related and hopefully it wouldn't be found a long winded answer
either.
Go for it.
I'll try to try to try to keep my inebriated as to a few sentences.
How would you,
or have you
had a balance,
a caloric surplus intensive hypertrophy regimen and routine,
but also mixed in intermittent fasting or Kenogenic?
Or is it just kind of,
you know,
they're binary.
You're either doing one or the other of our 87,
the way to mix the two,
you know,
some capacity.
Yeah,
I would say you're doing either,
well,
at least in my,
in my case you're doing one or the other.
So right now I'm in Tequila chocolate chip cookie,
like bullshit caloric surplus mode because I've been having a tough week.
So I've been just completely blowing every role and um,
yeah,
basically aging and dying as quickly as possible while getting fat in the
process.
So
yeah,
there's kind of that like garbage mode,
which is what I'm in right now.
I try not to do that too,
too often,
but I'm,
I'm currently there cause I've had a motherfucker of a couple of weeks.
And uh,
then you have the programmatic hypertrophy,
uh,
likely high insulin growth mode,
which is very much performance focused and not longevity focused.
And I will schedule periods during which I achieve ketosis and that is very
frequently through fasting.
So I will,
and this is something that should be done with medical supervision,
but I will do generally speaking through a minimum of three contiguous days of
fasting per month.
And then I will do five to 10 day fast,
at least once per year,
ideally three to four times per year.
And that is something that you should speak with your doctor about.
Uh,
but otherwise I do not generally sustain long periods of ketosis because I find
it so dietarily boring as all.
Fuck,
it's awful.
It's really,
really boring.
And this is particularly true if you remove dairy,
which I've tried to because my lipid profile goes sideways.
If I consume cheese and dairy while in Ketosis,
which is something that I've identified and which is not that uncommon in fact.
So I treat the,
I would say performance focused periods as quite separate from my longevity
slash autophagy focused periods,
which could involve fasting.
It could involve going hypo caloric,
it could involve intermittent fasting,
it could involve fast mimicking diets,
Alaa,
Victor Longo or any number of other things.
I don't currently use anything like metformin or Rapamycin,
but at some point could incorporate one or both of those and so on and so forth.
Uh,
but I do treat those as quite separate.
Much like looking at bodybuilders going through say bulking and cutting phases.
The,
although that's mostly aesthetically focused,
certainly reflects a certain,
uh,
caloric load and macronutrient ratio that I tend to alternate between.
I don't,
I,
I don't try to achieve both at the same time.
Yeah.
I appreciate you giving me a call and do what he returned to helping me out.
I'm trying to help me get started in going.
And,
uh,
the only thing I'm just curious and I was wondering,
can I take you to lunch sometime ago in Salt Lake?
Well,
you know what,
I might throw it up on social when I'm next there so you can keep an eye out for
that,
but I can't make any promises beyond that.
However,
uh,
I would like to ask that you just fucking get after it.
So we're recording this on a Thursday,
so I'd say this weekend and you are now an entrepreneur starting right now.
So don't quit your job and get started on testing the rest of it and your off
hours.
I appreciate it.
Of course.
My pleasure.
Have a great night.
Hello.
This is Joseph.
This is Joseph Timothy.
This is Timothy.
Good evening.
How are you sir?
I'm doing well.
I am all yours.
So please fire away.
What can I help with?
What can I answer if anything?
Like most people,
I'm sure.
I want to thank you for everything.
Um,
I found your book through the barbell shrugged guys.
Yeah.
Good crew.
Um,
and,
uh,
because of them I found podcasts and I found you and found your books and I've
become one of your,
uh,
what thousand true fans as Kevin Kelly would say.
So thank you.
Thank you for listening.
Well,
thank you for doing what you do.
So,
um,
so I know you,
you have a lot of projects and you're always,
um,
got a shit ton of balls in the air.
Um,
you know,
and I consider myself kind of a jack of many trades or a dilettante and training
if you will.
And with that comes like I have a diverse group of interests and things I like
to,
I'm always trying to pursue something different.
Um,
and you've talked several times about the advice that you were given when it
comes to picking projects that you only have like six rounds or bullets a year
and to pull the trigger on.
Um,
and the more that you try to,
if you try anymore,
it pulls you in too many directions.
So,
uh,
how do you pick projects and how do you know what to pull the trigger on and
what to let go?
Because I'm constantly trying to always look the next shiny object.
So
does a good question.
It's very timely for me as well because quite frankly I've taken on too many
projects and also realize that many of the projects I'm working on currently,
our legacy projects,
in other words,
the reasons for starting them seemed valid a year ago,
two years ago,
six months ago,
and now with new information,
with the ability to test those projects,
some of which have underperformed,
some of which have over performed,
there's an inclination to continue doing those things.
We've invested a lot into,
uh,
due to sunk cost fallacy and so on.
And I'm at a point right now where I'm reassessing not only the projects that I
might do new projects,
but really putting under scrutiny a lot of my current projects and the way that
I'm going about that right now is number one,
doing a lot of hypothetical journaling or it's actually real journaling,
but based on hypothetical questions and namely,
if I stop doing x,
what might be the upside?
What might,
how,
how might it be a good thing or a great thing?
Projects that I've put a lot of energy,
time,
capital resources into,
right?
And forcing myself to write out a full page of bullets or a full page of
sentences for each of these projects that is consuming a disproportionate amount
of my time primarily.
So if we're looking at 80 20 analysis,
which is something I come back to repeatedly,
Plato's law and so on for our work,
we can elsewhere that I've written about it yet,
we're,
I'll ask myself what are the 20% of projects right now that are consuming 80% or
more of my time?
Or what are the 20% of projects or relationships that are currently producing
80% or more of the phone calls,
conference calls,
email,
and other types of,
in most cases,
noise,
right?
And those go on the chopping block for consideration for elimination.
And really what I've realized for myself and um,
but what I'm going through right now is recognizing that it's always easier to
look at the shiny new project versus looking at your current roster and deciding
which children to kill in terms as it relates to project.
So I'm trying very hard not to say yes to new things until I've streamlined my
current operations,
right?
If you're 10% from the breaking point at all times and you've take on more
projects,
it's a foregone conclusion that eventually that's not going to work.
And,
uh,
so currently I literally just did this last night.
I sit down,
I'm spending time on morning pages,
uh,
as,
as I've written about before.
So Julia Cameron morning pages,
and,
uh,
I'm also doing a
80,
an 80,
20 analysis on the positive side.
Uh,
and that,
that applies on a few different dimensions.
Number one is financial,
right?
So I'm looking at where the income is actually coming from and what are the,
the handful of projects or activities in my case,
let's just say podcast,
uh,
and a handful of other things,
that generally generate the vast majority of monthly annual income.
And then looking at ways to streamline that.
And the,
the question that I would ask there,
which is something I've wrote about,
I believe in tribe of mentors,
was what might this look like if it were easy?
Right?
So,
uh,
the,
the way I'm answering your question maybe somewhat dissatisfying,
but the point being that it's what I've learned over time is that you really
need to basically put your current projects in front of the judge and jury for
possible execution before you even consider what to say yes to in the new
category on the new category.
What I might look at our projects that are tasks that make the other possible
projects and tasks either irrelevant or much easier.
For instance,
I'm looking at,
uh,
say,
I'll give you a list of projects that could be on my plate.
One would be doing a nother book similar to tribe of mentors,
or I have a hundred to 200 experts of various types weighing in,
answering the same set of,
or a similar set of questions.
The next could be I work on a feature film screenplay that I then intend to
produce and direct or at least produce to have some creative control over.
Uh,
then I could put on that same list.
I want to from soup to nuts,
start to finish,
beg,
borrow,
and to get Robert Rodriguez attention to from the first word of the screenplay
to the finished product work on a handful of short films and and so on and so
forth and what what if I look at those three,
I might decide that it's in my best interest to not do the the feature film
first because I would learn so much through the process with Robert before doing
that,
that it would behoove me to tackle a handful of short films or even one or two
so that that will better inform the decisions I make with the higher stakes
project,
which would be the feature film.
I made further decide that it makes sense to do another book where perhaps I
invite the 20 to 50 figures and entertainment and feature film and so on who I
might lay a lot to collaborate with to contribute in some fashion.
Right.
And in that sense,
I think about the logical progression that will make each subsequent project
easier.
And I remember I heard it said at one point,
this might have been from Tony Robbins,
but I may be misattributing it,
that we could have been who knows any number of people in any case,
ineffective that we overestimate what we can achieve say in a day or a month,
but we underestimate what we can get done in three to five years or 10 years.
And for me it's come down to realizing that you can do,
you can actually do everything just about everything.
You just can't do it at the same time.
So you have to figure out the logical progression that puts you ahead and when
in doubt,
choosing projects that help you to develop skills and relationships that
transcend any single given project because you might look at,
for instance,
a single project liked four hour chef,
which was a tremendous amount of work.
It was a huge investment of time.
It was a suicidal schedule,
very proud of the outcome.
But ultimately from a commercial standpoint,
because it was the first major acquisition and through Amazon publishing,
it was boycotted everywhere and the sales were,
were quite disappointing to me,
certainly because we didn't have the distribution necessary and you could look
at that as an abject failure.
But in doing that for print distribution,
I got to know the people at Hmh Houghton Mifflin Harcourt,
which then went on to publish tools of titans and tribe of mentors,
both of which ended up being number one.
So I develop the relationship with those people,
was able to kick the tires,
learn their strengths and weaknesses while also developing other skills.
Then later informed bigger projects,
arguably speaking.
Uh,
so that's,
that's a long answer,
but I would encourage you to also pick up a book.
It's very short.
I've read it dozens of times called the effective executive.
In fact,
saying it right now makes me realize that I should reread it myself.
But the effective executive by Peter Drucker would be one place,
uh,
that I would also turn to as a resource when trying to make decisions about your
time,
which ultimately every decision or almost every decision comes down to.
Um,
so those would be,
those would be a few guidelines that I would suggest,
uh,
at least as having been helpful for me in the past.
So
basically figuring out what you're doing that's sucking all the energy that you
could be using on something that you would care more about and get rid of those
and then go back and,
uh,
when you're picking new projects and figure out what your end goal is and figure
out the best project that will get you the skill to get you the end goal,
even if it doesn't take you directly there.
Right.
The,
the,
the progression of projects that will get you to one longer term objective,
even if it's just a placeholder,
that may totally change.
But as long as you're amassing skills and developing relationships,
those are more adaptable than is important.
The report card for any single project,
at least of your thinking longer term.
So that would make sense.
Yeah,
that'd be my recommendation.
Uh,
all right.
If you have one more that short,
I'll take a stab at it.
But otherwise,
uh,
we can,
we can decide how to do it before
you always talk about your five people.
Who are your five people?
Yeah,
this is a,
a good question.
And the five people change.
Uh,
so I,
I would say that very often they are.
I mean,
they're almost always close friends of mine just by,
by virtue of the question,
you know,
who are the five people you associate with most?
And for those people who don't have the context,
uh,
I,
and many other people have said,
you know,
you are the average of the five people you associate with most,
whether it's physically,
emotionally,
psychologically,
whatever it might be.
Uh,
remotely.
I still spend a lot of time with close friends of mine who I admire and aspire
to be more like in certain ways.
Neval Robert Kahn,
Kevin Rose,
Matt Mullenweg would,
would all be on my list.
Then looking at say people closer to me geographically now since I live in
Austin,
Texas,
you would have Robert Rodriguez,
I think Aubrey Marcus CEO of on it actually has a lot figured out and not only
figured out but implemented in a very systematic way that,
uh,
is,
is hard to appreciate until you've actually spent a lot of time around him.
Uh,
and so forth and so on.
I would say ray Daleo is also on that list.
I don't,
I don't spend as much time with him as I would like,
but certainly from a reasoning from and planning from first principles
perspective,
one of the more impressive guys that you'll ever come across.
So those are a few folks on my list and they all have a lot of writing and
recording out there.
So it's possible to learn from them even if you don't know them directly.
Uh,
all right,
my friend.
Well,
I'll tell you what I need to keep drinking and keep so you have
a wonderful night and appreciate the questions.
Hi,
is this Regina?
Oh my God,
this,
hi.
It's,
it's uh,
this is Tim Ferriss.
I'm looking at your area code is late as hell.
Where you are?
I'm not going to,
yeah,
I um,
it's,
it's late,
but it's okay.
No,
you are my last call of the evening,
so I appreciate you being awake.
Are you game for a short conversation?
I am.
Yeah.
All right,
perfect.
Well,
I guess,
uh,
I guess it's what does,
it is probably like two 30 in the morning or something like that where you are
maybe one,
one 30 in the morning.
In any case,
uh,
I am,
well warmed up and happy to try to answer any questions that you might have.
I can't make any quality guarantees,
but I will certainly give it a shot.
So how can I help?
So first,
thank you for calling my pleasure.
Um,
and I guess my first question is whose I am the last call,
how much have you partaken?
Ah,
fine question I've had and I would say five moderate glasses of Tequila and
soda.
So I am,
I'm very much,
uh,
I'm not going to say levitating,
but uh,
I feel light on my feet,
which I think is more a reflection of the alcohol than anything else,
but I'm not completely incoherent,
so it's a good middle ground.
I would say
that's decent.
Then I guess my question for you,
it would be a good one because I would have a hard problem with it.
How do you come up with questions to ask people to ask the right questions to be
a good interviewer so that you are getting to know them very well or getting the
right answers or the answers they're interesting for your listeners.
The way I approach that is not thinking of my listeners at all.
Quite frankly.
I asked the questions that relate to
personal pains or personal goals or dreams that I have and I assume that that
will apply to some percentage of my listeners,
but it's a very personal journey for me.
And,
uh,
there,
there there's a bit more planning to it in the sense that if I'm talking to
someone who is very,
very frequently interviewed,
who has a lot of public exposure,
then I will try to avoid questions.
They were frequently asked for the first say 20 to 30 minutes of the interview.
Uh,
but if we're looking at the overarching approach,
I would say it is intense curiosity and a focus on my own personal needs that
drives the questions I ask.
Okay.
Right.
That makes sense.
You've been asked quite a lot of questions and you've told us quite a lot.
Um,
I guess over the years about things that probably we already had Ashton's for.
I would like to know the attitude because I struggle with that just in general
personally because I'm more of a listener than a talker.
So I'm even amongst like the thought of dating or a friend or something like
that.
I find that hard to come up with questions,
then make the other person feel like I'm interested because I'm usually the type
of person that's like anything that I'm told or how things just unfold naturally
is how I,
um,
I guess I feel comfortable.
Yes.
Learning about someone.
The questions don't have to be,
yeah.
I mean,
the questions don't have to be sophisticated at all.
In fact,
one way to ask questions is just to be quiet.
So I was told by cal Fussman who wrote the,
what I learned column for Esquire for decades and primarily wrote that column,
interviewed everyone from Jewish clean,
neat and corporate chef to a prison in a Bush and so on.
And every single celebrity in between,
he told me at one point,
let the silence do the work.
You don't have to ask questions per se to be a good conversationalist,
but there are also very,
very short questions that you can ask following almost any statement from
someone else,
such as,
you know,
what did you learn from that?
Or how did that make you feel?
Uh,
they're,
they're very,
very short questions that you can ask that can then prompt someone to talk for
two to five to 10 minutes.
Uh,
it doesn't have to be anything groundbreaking or particularly innovative in,
in fact,
if you try to come up with really clever questions at very often comes off as
disingenuous or artificial.
Uh,
so simple tends to work really well in my experience.
Okay.
Um,
well I guess like the piggy back off of that,
my other,
um,
things that I always feel like I'm asking a question that might be a little too
personal.
Do you ever feel that way?
Like when you're thinking of things as long as the conversation,
like how do I ask this question or is this too much
will be an example of a question you might ask that would be too personal
sometimes.
I guess it's for me,
I'm the type of person that I grew up like as a child and I was younger.
I grew up with a lot of like my family members being older than me because I'm
the youngest.
I was always in that situation where it was like a child safe and a child's
please,
you don't ask that question or you know,
um,
you only talk when spoken to kind of thing,
like when I was younger and it's kind of rolled over.
So he mean even something as simple as if I'm dating someone or like asking
questions,
get to know each other,
I'm asking anything.
Like how to know which question is asking about the past or asking about,
you know,
past people they feed it or things like that.
Like how,
you know,
what happened at the end of the last relationship.
Like sometimes I feel like that question might be a little too personal for
someone.
I'm just asking them off of that and I kind of wait for that conversation to be
brought up by them so that it's bought it online,
they're comfortable with.
Um,
so I guess that kind of stops me from asking a lot of the questions.
I am curious because I don't want to come off too forward.
Uh,
well I don't know if the question is too personal.
They might just be too early.
Right.
So,
yeah,
in a context like that,
you don't want to jump from like the intellectual equivalent of like a pat on
the shoulder to like heavy petting and 10 seconds flat.
Right?
You don't want to just emote emotionally sideswipe someone we're like,
Holy Shit,
like this woman's asking me about like my most embarrassing,
humiliating moment of my life and we barely got drinks already.
Right?
Okay,
this is,
this is too much for me to handle.
Uh,
is that the only context?
Are there other contexts?
Is it primarily in a dating context that you're concerned about this?
Are there other contexts where this affects you?
Um,
well,
for the past year I'm still learning how to be a travel agent.
So,
you know,
like in sales it's just asking them qualifying questions,
asking the right questions.
I'm asking questions to build rapport.
So,
um,
sometimes you know,
like you're bringing someone,
then some people tell you things that you may not have you been wanting to know,
but they just kind of roll along with the conversation and they let themselves,
like they just talk.
And that's kind of where I feel more comfortable.
But then when it's an essence where you have someone who you want to try it,
because I'm kind of an introvert,
so it's a lot easier for me to listen to someone else talk when they just want
me to try to facilitate that conversation to make it flow so that it does seem
natural.
Like I'm having a conversation with them,
but also getting information I need to give them,
um,
the product that they're looking for because they don't know necessarily what
they're looking for.
That's why they've come to us.
If I have to ask them the questions to get those answers,
to provide something that makes them feel like I understand.
Yeah,
totally.
Uh,
so the first and foremost being an introvert is not a handicap.
I am very much,
I would do myself as an introvert who can pretend to be an extrovert for limited
periods of time.
Yeah.
Don't get fancy.
So for instance,
when someone's telling you something,
you can just say,
tell me more about that.
Really give me the,
give me an example.
Could you tell me more about that?
How does that make you feel?
Why is this important?
I mean,
there are,
there are questions like that which are very,
very simple that keeps someone talking and eventually they're going to give you
that nugget of information that helps you to better design a solution for them
or find the answer to a specific need they had that which they couldn't
articulate.
If you simply ask them what do you need,
they wouldn't be able to give you the right answer.
Uh,
so I w I mean if you really just had five to 10 of these followup questions
noted down on a piece of paper in front of you,
you would be able to pick and choose,
which,
by the way,
is exactly what I often do or did,
at least for the first hundred podcasts that I,
I don't on this show.
So it's,
it's,
there's no shame in that.
I think that it's very,
very helpful to have a goto portfolio of followup questions,
which are very,
very short and very,
very simple to keep people talking,
uh,
in,
in at least a sales context.
And that's true for a,
my experience for dating as well.
If you didn't want to ask about how their last relationship ended,
right?
You could ask them like,
well how did you end up using Tinder?
Like how,
how long have you been doing Dah,
Dah,
uh,
what led you to that?
Right?
You can ask questions which get them to the same end,
which out with without coming off as like the psycho who's going for the juggler
right away.
Do you know what I mean?
And like,
trust me,
I've,
I've been there,
I've been that person.
Right?
Like I get it.
But it's like you can,
you can,
you can kind of tip toe around it while leading them to the story of what
brought them to where they are today without being exceptionally direct about
it.
And for instance,
if I'm interviewing someone who's dealt with a scandal and my podcast isn't
about scandals,
it's not about Gotcha.
But maybe I want to explore the emotional terrain that reflects how they reacted
to some very difficult set of circumstances.
If I,
if I ask them directly,
how did you respond to this event that happened when such and such person
accused you of such and such thing,
they're going to shut down.
That is a nonstarter.
But if I asked them and I know something happened within the last three years
and I asked them,
you know,
could you,
could you tell me,
people listening to this podcast will think based on your bio,
based on all the successes you've had,
that every time you step up to the plate,
you hit home runs.
And I feel like that is inspiring on one hand,
but very,
uh,
intimidating on the other.
So I'd like to try to humanize you a bit.
Can you tell us about a really difficult situation or a circumstance in the last
handful of years and how you responded to it?
Right.
Framing it that way opens the door to allow them to introduce it without hitting
them with a full frontal assault that is going to make them defensive.
Right.
That makes sense.
Yeah.
So that's,
that's an indirect way to approach something that allows someone else to feel
like they're taking the initiative and introducing a topic that may be
uncomfortable to them.
And I think that's my biggest problem is because I'm afraid to ask the question
in any way and then the other person may be,
feels like all of us,
you know,
she's not a good conversation or she doesn't care,
um,
to ask anything about me because she never asked any questions that are deeper
than the typical question.
So I can ask him direct questions that makes a conversation start falling and
gives them control over what they tell me.
Furthermore,
I would,
I would recommend that you practice when it doesn't matter,
right?
So don't just practice with sales prospects.
Don't just practice with people you're dating,
you have the hots for and that you want to have babies with.
Don't do that.
Like wait,
like actually,
you know what I mean?
Where you're like,
oh my God,
this one could be the one.
Like that's not the time to practice.
The time to practice is when you hear like talking to like fucking Joe blow in
line at Starbucks.
You're like,
I don't give a shit.
Well this guy thinks like that's the time,
that's the time to practice.
And it's this,
it's the same skillset.
It is the same tool kit is the same portfolio of Goto questions that you can
utilize on a regular basis.
So you develop a level,
a baseline level of comfort with this repertoire so that you can then as second
nature,
use it very naturally when it matters.
So that would be my,
one of my recommendations is practice when it doesn't matter
whether that is negotiating a pickup line,
a follow up question,
a simple way of bridging one topic to the next,
really go out of your way to practice when it doesn't matter.
Okay.
Yeah,
that makes,
that makes sense.
So then my other question would be
how I'd actually don't have a lot of situations where I could ask those
questions where it doesn't matter because I pretty much just go to work,
go to the gym and then come home.
Yeah.
So,
I mean,
well actually I guess I've kind of already been doing that.
Um,
cause I,
I cross it so it's know like eight people,
10 people,
um,
with the classes,
the times that I go to.
And I've kind of already been trying to talk more with people at class as
opposed to just like going to class,
going to the shower and leaving.
Um,
and I'll kind of already been doing that.
But I guess I can start making those fat list of followup questions that help
move the conversation along to get to know people aren't talking about.
Um,
that definitely helps having things set already.
Cause I work better that way when I kind of already know how I'm supposed to do
things.
Yeah.
I mean you have a right getting index card,
write down the five questions and just make it happen.
You're not going to find time to do it.
So you have to create time to do it.
And that could be,
you know,
the boyfriend watching the dog while his girlfriend's doing some,
God awful,
you know,
Francis crossfit workout or whatever.
Well it's all right.
That's the guy you're like,
all right,
that's my dude.
That's the guy I'm practicing on.
Walk over like,
Hey,
what's your fucking dogs name?
Oh,
cool.
Really?
Like,
how'd you choose that dog?
Oh Wow.
What's the story behind that?
Right.
That's another good question.
Like what's the story behind that?
Huh?
How'd you decide on why?
That's interesting.
That's interesting to me.
Tell me more about that.
Like,
tell me more about that as such a lazy,
useful statement.
How did you decide that?
How did that make you feel?
That sounds crazy.
I don't know how I'd respond to that.
Okay,
boom.
And then you got another three.
You just bought a three to five minute story and just practice that stuff.
You have to,
you're not going to find time to do it,
so you have to make time to do it.
If you make it a priority,
it will serve you.
If you don't make it a priority,
it's not going to help you.
Uh,
so that would be in my drunken stupor,
Yodel,
like line that may or may not help.
I think that was a very coherent
answer.
A fantastic,
well I should let you get some sleep and I should probably also take my dog out
for a walk and do the same thing.
So,
uh,
I think
my pleasure and good luck this stuff.
Honestly listen to my first few podcasts,
especially the first one when Kevin Rose busting my balls.
It's rough.
It's really,
really rough.
This is a craft.
This is something you can learn and practice and I really believe anyone can get
better at it because it is so straight forward.
If you make the time,
how you can deliver a questions to humans you encounter,
it's not,
it's not difficult or it's not complex.
You just have to put yourself out there and endure a small amount of discomfort
with the uncertainty of how someone will respond.
And if you're willing to do that,
you can get a lot better at this in a very,
very short period of time.
Hey guys,
this is Tim again.
Just a few more things before you take off.
Number one,
this is five bullet Friday.
Do you want to get a short email from me?
Would you enjoy getting a short email from me every Friday that provides a
little more soul of fun before the weekend and five bullet Fridays,
a very short email where I share the coolest things I've found or that I've been
pondering over the week.
That could include favorite new albums that I've discovered.
It could include Gizmos and gadgets and all sorts of weird shit that I've
somehow dug up in the uh,
the world of the esoteric I do.
It could include favorite articles that I've read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance.
And it's very short.
It's just a little tiny bite of goodness before you head off for the weekend.
So if you want to receive that,
check it out.
Just go to four hour work week.com that's four hour work week.com all spelled
out and just drop in your email and you will get the very next one.
And if you sign up,
I hope you enjoy it.
This episode is brought to you by 99 designs.
Whether you need a logo,
custom website,
APP,
book cover or anything else.
99 designs was created to make great design accessible to everyone that's you
and to make the process as easy as possible.
I've used 99 designs for years now I've used the book covers some mockups for
the four hour body which went on to become a number one New York Times best
seller illustrations of all different types for the multivolume,
the Tao of Seneca,
which you can check out and other graphic design projects for a long time now
and I've been very impressed with the quality of their designers and
illustrators and you don't have to take my word for it.
You should check out some of my projects@ninetyninedesigns.com forward slash it
Tim,
I really encourage you to take a look because you will be impressed.
99 designs.com/tim and nine nine designs has freelance experts in more than 90
design categories in their platform.
Lets you work directly with one designer that you choose.
If you like their stuff,
which is what I did for the town of Seneca,
or you can get concepts from multiple designers and then pick your favorite.
So whether you're starting a business or just looking for extra design,
help,
resources,
et cetera.
99 designs has a solution right now.
You guys,
my listeners can receive a free $99 upgrade on your first design.
To check out your first free upgrade,
please visit 99 designs.com forward slash Tim and click the link on the landing
page.
You can also find their samples of projects from you guys,
listeners who've used 99 designs for logos,
apps,
even product packaging,
so check it out.
99 designs.com forward slash.
Tim,
this episode of the Tim Ferriss show is brought to you by linked in.
More specifically,
I'm referring to Linkedin's job recruitment platform,
which is a great way to find and hire the quality talent that you need in your
organization.
You already know,
of course,
Linkedin as the world's largest professional network,
and in fact 70% of the US workforce is already on Linkedin in 22 million
professionals.
View and apply to jobs on linkedin every week given those numbers.
It's not surprising at all that there've been hundreds of thousands of
businesses that have posted to linkedin jobs over the past year alone,
and because linkedin considers skills,
experiences location and much more,
they just have better data to match and promote your job to potential
candidates.
The most qualified candidates,
unlike other generic job boards,
businesses have rated linked in jobs 40% better than job boards at delivering
quality candidates.
Let's check it out.
Go to linkedin.com/tim and get $50 off your first job post.
That's linkedin.com/tim for York.
$50 off today.
Terms and conditions apply.